of mathematica wool from desktop for
upcoming version and we're looking at
that on Windows machine so we're
starting from the we're going to be
going through both design functional
design and graphic design aspects this
is a very big clunky looking I mean it
seems well so it's a one of the things
to understand right up front is that we
are for the first time believing what
the operating system tells us when when
we asked what the resolution of a given
monitor is and in version 12 in previous
under windows and under linux we've
always said we've always just hard-coded
you know 72 DPI and it doesn't matter
what monitor you had hooked up we said
it was sending through DPI windows helps
us a little bit in the in a high DPI
monitor cases by kind of faking stuff
out but it's all based on 72 dpi that
was never what Windows was telling us
not once even for low res monitors
Windows was telling us 96 dpi and that
means when you start believing Windows
things get bigger okay but but not
everything I mean like this isn't bigger
the so there are some sizes of fonts I
don't know be able to comment on this
one but there are some sizes of fonts
that we get from the system like the
menu that the menu fonts they're yours
so that menu is very tiny looking and
also those things look very very very
close together to me they are the
default font size for menus on windows
if you wanted to know the exact value
let's start looking here I mean this
looks absolutely monstrously huge I mean
that to us who looks playschool huge it
that is a 13 point font and if we and
I've done this experiment multiple times
we can do it again if you would like to
do it right now
but if you took WordPad and did the
exact same font with the exact same font
size
they would they would match so I mean if
I were to look here at um just let's see
if I go to off malphur for example and I
start okay so those are pretty sober
sized things um so it's I type in 100
factorial here oh my god what was that
did you see that did you see those giant
grace grey squares yes I didn't know
what it was but I saw them Jeremy is
Jeremy here I saw them that's not a
speck I'm not sure what that was my god
yeah well that's the edge browser so
yeah I'm not seeing the same thing in my
edge okay so here these are kind of soba
sized fonts that are you know those are
those are those are bitmaps remember oh
that's right so we have control over
that okay but but this looks way too big
to me so what what is the font size that
we are picking so this comes from the
style sheet is that right yes boy it
really looks too big to me
what does Jeremy think about this I mean
I don't understand why I mean okay so
the big problem is there's a huge visual
difference between what it looks like on
Windows and Mac I mean it's it's you
know on both systems we asked the system
for a 13-point fonts and this is the
difference okay so one possibility is
that we could have a default
magnification it isn't a hundred percent
on Windows well then points aren't
points anymore well at least you know
that there's a magnification well I mean
if we do it for the user do they know
there is a mataf occasion they're
sitting right there in the magnification
in other words that we bring it up I
mean that is we already made the
decision recently when you deploy to the
cloud for example it's going to ignore
the magnification of unless you tell it
otherwise of the deploying notebook so
to speak it's going to independently
decide what the magnification is based
on the fact slowing in a browser on the
cloud we could do the same thing here we
could say the magnification is the
responsibility of the of the viewing
system so so Macintosh and Linux are
wrong across the board only sorry
Windows and Linux or re across the board
only Macintosh gets the virtue of having
a correct hundred percent magnification
well we can do it the way around I mean
but but what what what we're being was
why is it that a 13-point font looks
huge on the Windows machine and does not
look huge on the Mac because Mac claims
to us that it's either as depending on
whether it's a Retina display or not
claims thus that it's either 72 or 144
DPI now if if you take that ruler that's
on your desk or where on your other desk
is probably not on the desk here in
front of now and you measure it that
turns out typically to be wrong I it was
it was kind of worms it was right once
upon a time
you know monitors have gotten better and
windows by the way has been saying 96
what does it what else would do does
would come up with 100% of this would
come up at a different magnification
I would came up with magnification word
by default I was just looking at it
earlier this morning word on both
Windows and Mac default to a hundred
percent so if you if you do like yo new
document how can that work well there
are different sizes what do ya mean ya
know they know no same font size but
different visual appearances if you look
at word on if you took a Word document
like you know typed in foo in like you
know like a 13 point font doesn't matter
the font and look did that on Windows it
would have one visual size you save it
put it on your Dropbox or whatever open
it up on Mac if the text is smaller okay
but look I'm looking at a web page I'm
looking at my personal home page which i
think is just textual HTML and and by
the way words words defaults are indeed
a bit smaller I mean you know it's you
bring up we're a modern word you're
getting Calibri 11 points okay so I
didn't a 70 percent - 75 percent
magnification I mean to me this looks
pretty reasonable this kind of matches
here it you know this looks fairly
reasonable um Karl on our live stream is
asking are we talking about Windows yes
we're talking about Windows this is
about Windows if you don't care about
Windows you're probably not gonna care
about well except that we're realizing
that there's there's Horrors all over
the place yeah the UM it is it's not
just windows by the way it affects Linux
- okay all right so okay let me let me
roll the possibilities out okay I think
the idea of defaulting to non 100% is
not completely stupid okay given given
the can of worms that we have we've
either got at standard DPI at like a
standard res monitor an on high DPI
monitor not a hundred percent would look
really bad for lots of cases like any
pixel based art would look horrible you
know CA with you know its pixel position
like one or two it would look horrible
there's you know lots of these edge
cases well but but the whole X the whole
pixel perfect thing is you know that's
another problem that is you know it's
gonna be very you know being pixel
perfect is not a thing that we can do
anymore the I mean we can't even do it
on the same system because you might
have two monitors that have two
different resolutions which are not even
integer multiples of one another that's
entirely possible
okay so that's this which is nice and
crisp at least for me I don't know what
it's like for you got and this is also
bizarre I thought pixel constrained oh
no one just says it's one this is
freakin bizarre because my resolution
the resolution of my monitor is much
higher than this so why did it think the
pixel constrained is not something that
we can do anymore well what is pixel
constrain mean when I can drag the
window what just happened my something
very bizarre just happens um I pressed
command Li thing are you pressing
Windows L which is yeah well for press
ENTER or whatever it should get you to a
login prompt somewhere yeah I just
normally get control so it's I have to
not hit the Windows key too often okay I
was trying to do command L control L
okay you can tell which of us in this
meeting use Windows regularly by the way
very crisp that looks very very crisp
and they Wow well pixel profile
constrain one doesn't look particularly
good actually well and you know I mean
my point is I
I don't think pixel constrained even
works anymore I mean I think we just
have to deprecated it because it's you
know it's it's too easy to I I mean we
we really you know hack you could start
the evaluation on one monitor move the
window for one monitor to the other
while it's computing on you you know
sure I'm not used to my fingers are not
used to the okay ah how do I get a a
command for is it all yeah that font is
kind of sucky looking isn't it is that
our analogous I mean it looks much
thinner than our font on other machines
source sans Pro the way that is yeah
looks like it's not in gold
oh no it's not deme bold it I have to
look at the stylesheet is it supposed to
be yeah
yes it should be both of them this
[Music]
so I mean the thing that really bugs me
is the difference between these these
sort of system things and the I mean -
you're telling me yes III I don't see I
see a font-weight setting for section in
the default style sheet source hints Pro
font size 2028 my in the wrong Oh wrong
section yeah yes so what should I do
here could I could I set this to demo
I'll just assume they're like sure style
you can do it under font and there's
semi bold there which is the same thing
the most elegant font in the world what
what is it the exact same font is on the
Mac currently or is it - I think so the
the source code ones come from the you
know the layout which we redistribute
and it should be identical sure yeah
it's the same yeah
it just looks bad because it's so big
yeah yes it will obviously as we've
discussed via different size but yes the
kerning different am I going crazy at
learn I've got a Mac here which I can't
really put on zoom but um no okay
and actually it doesn't even look dummy
bold on my Mac right yes it is it is
plain on Macintosh I just confirmed so
yeah okay
all right so that's that was not not
relevant
so if we say I'm
all right fine okay all right so listen
first though that that's obtained a 5%
buy it by the way I Carl egg makes
another point which I like very much
what's that oh I live stream on the live
stream yes pixel constraint is even more
crazy on mobile devices yeah yes what do
you think and be like does on a mobile
device when you
well the so pixel constrained is as I
recall it's a it's a kernel thing it's
not a front end it doesn't yeah it might
do yeah it's oh yeah who even knows fine
all right but but I'm so I'm actively
lobbying to deprecate least we could put
some commentary in the documentation for
12-1 saying that it is I'm happy to
write tons of commentary I don't have a
problem with that so let's let's put
some commentary in pixel constrained for
twelve one and expect that as high DPI
becomes more common it'll just disappear
sure sure okay so let's go back here -
okay I'm still concerned about the
sizing here does it not bother you I
mean a you are you like used to seeing
things of this size well you know it's
I've I'm running my daily builds or my
nightly look at this yes yes we know we
know we know it's a bug in the Ian's
already has a pull request open for it
we know well John would you write code
with fonts at that size well it depends
my eyes are getting worse with it you
know I can't believe it'd be true
because that doesn't look like yes it's
a little large for me but it's not out
it's not like gigantically large though
but but you know you're asking me for my
opinion on design what do you think
no well overly large yeah to me it looks
overly large so what are we going to do
about it I mean the question is living
with it just because this font size
arose from something like oh we
understand
understand it's not just the font size
it's everything
I mean image size the same thing is
happening image size okay but so the
only thing that would work is to go to a
different magnification and Jeremy is
concerned that that would lead to other
things happening but but we could you
know whatever if it was different
magnification they might be already
happening now without Maxo fication like
the stuff I'm worried about might
already be slow well this is already
fuzzy so I mean yeah anyway exactly
so bug don't worry about this that's
just a bug okay fine
this is just ridiculously big here let's
look at what this would look like it's
75% looks pretty reasonable to me at 75%
now it's my monitor I mean I have a big
honking monitor here so now in you know
it no so here's something else to happen
window size scaled to in what sense
window size is documented and has always
been documented to be in points not
pixels we have treated it sometimes as
if it were pixels but it's never been
documented that way okay and window size
is not subject to magnification at least
not presently it I mean we go to pooey
and yes I've I've never raised before
yes it's this can make you Ingrid
we could make window size subject to
magnification but would have some
potentially strange and maybe very
undesirable consequences okay so look
what I propose is that we I mean again
you can shoot this down but I'm
proposing that we try 75% or something I
mean we could try and it's 80% 75% what
is the ratio of 11 point to 13 point
hmm 84% okay so let's say 80%
magnification and by the way if we're
gonna do it by the way it technically is
75% it I mean for you know it's 72
versus 96 dpi
if for a low-res monitor 2 versus 96
right that that's for a low-res monitor
and you know if you have 200% scaled
it's gonna kind of you know work out the
same way but there but there are all
kinds of scalings that happen under
windows I mean you can so a hundred
percent scaling is the 96 dpi but you
can have a hundred twenty five percent
scaling it's not theoretical people buy
machines that are by default scale two
hundred twenty-five percent yeah
independent so in other words then then
we would be if we set our magnification
was such and such then we will be D
magnifying back to hundred percent let's
say so in other words they would take
our 75 percent magnification and scale
it up to hundred and twenty five percent
they would scale the whole OS up a
hundred I understand that our font size
effectively here would turn in and and
we would scale back down yeah so I mean
so it's wait a sec wait what do you mean
we would scale back down why wouldn't
they be scaling we would scale back down
from their expanded hundred and
twenty-five percent not we wouldn't
scale down
we wouldn't be wouldn't we're scaling
down from points what points we're
scaling down from points I'm confused
okay seventy-five percent when you say
magnification set to 75 percent or 100
percent what does that mean that means
that you had a thing before which say
was was you know let's let's say it was
an image it was 200 there was a hundred
points across means is now 75 points the
control panel so it's that little gear
icon
I don't know if changing this would be a
good idea during a live stream but this
may seriously mess up your live stream
but you can look at it the options
system and then scroll down on the right
hand side so that hundred and fifty
percent recommended oh my god what is
that that's crazy
what's what that it's a hundred and
fifty percent why is it crazy did what
you did just use your ruler on the
monitor maybe it's exactly right because
this monitor is extremely high
resolution you're saying yes yeah what
Microsoft is doing is and and I'm not
gonna describe the the algorithm because
I don't even think they fully described
it but effectively what it is is they
take the raw resolution of the display
so in this case thirty-eight something
something by what would that be twenty
one thousand something something like
that and then they asked the LCD what
the physical dimensions are in inches or
actually in that case it's going to be a
millimeters and then they do some math
to figure out what they consider to be
readable stuff right exactly so we're
going to assume that applications are
throwing up things in ten point type but
ten points by ten point they okay by ten
point type that is translated to mean
ten pixels but ten pixels on this
display will be microscopic so they're
expanding it to be more pixels
even though points should have been
points but isn't points because it's
pixels is that correct
they they take so like if you look at
the docs for how they want you to
specify font size and points is is that
they basically apply a one hundred and
thirty three percent increase to it and
then the pixels would take off from
there so basically you can think of it
as
and point font times 1 times 133 percent
to get it into pixels and then times the
hundred and fifty percent that you see
there you can think of it as a totally
bonkers I mean the 133 percent to get to
pixels is because what on an old sort of
toaster that was how it worked is that
right I mean why is there a hundred 33%
to get from points well they wanted it
to be easier to read and so they know
well well okay so many many decades ago
you know Microsoft had this notion that
that you know there was a big difference
between reading a 10-point font on a
sheet of paper and then 10-point font on
a screen right and so they introduced
this factor to make you know in their
view you know the font on the screen as
readable as if it had been on paper now
I'm not absolutely certain though
whether this you know scaling factor is
you know how much it's really still a
thing though I I think that I mean you
know I've just done a little bit of
checking but I think monitors have
gotten the truth of monitors has gotten
much closer to Microsoft's exaggeration
if you understand what I mean by that
you know I'm totally confused even feel
free to just disagree with that but I
think that's the case
ok let's let's zoom out so in other
words it used to be that a you know low
res monitor was basically about 72 dpi
and you did this in 1996 you pulled your
ruler out you put on the screen and you
said it's 72 dpi look at that and we had
the same discussion about Microsoft you
don't remember it but I do back in 1996
but but if you were to do the same thing
on a low res monitor today you would
find it much closer 90s I'm gonna try
doing something here this may blow up a
live stream I'm gonna try changing my
display 200% okay
hmm didn't blow anything up can you
still see that yes yes God and God did
it get smaller thing yes yes yes okay so
let's now look at 100% magnification
here
oh that's magnificent I mean that's
about the right size at a hundred
percent magnification all right now of
course the menu finds is a Cristal
microscopic that but this is so in other
words this size if I were to compare
that how does that compare do you think
I mean you can't tell because your
monitors are different from right but to
me this looks a little bit small but not
outrageously let me I have a Mac laptop
right here I mean I could I could use
the KVM switch and then you wouldn't be
able to see what I could see because
I'll be on a different I could I could
connect actually I could connect no I
could connect the the alternate KVM now
I've got a linux box here as well um
yeah I mean to me yeah I mean on my Mac
I'm looking at a Mac laptop I'm looking
at this hundred percent size um the UM
and this looks to be physically about
the same size at a hundred percent
declared resolution for the for the
Windows machine it looks to be about the
same physical size as my hundred-percent
on a Mac does that surprise you no no
okay so a hundred percent if the
declared size on the Windows machine is
a hundred percent if the operating
system declared size is a hundred
percent
but-but-but what I'm suggesting is that
one of them is lying to you and I
wouldn't assume it's the windows one I
understand that I understand but what
I'm saying is
both of them I'd be lying to you that's
frankly possible as well yeah okay but
what I'm saying is that at a hundred
percent declared size on the Windows
machine right our font choices look okay
well they were designed for that size so
that I understand but the Windows
machine decided of its own volition so
to speak to scale everything 250 percent
right that caused our fonts to look
gigantic because our fonts were correct
had it had it taken a hundred percent
but now they um okay so let's let's look
here so then we go back two hundred
fifty percent let's watch it do its
thing that was very undignified of this
Windows machine that was very
undignified that it moved that window it
did not move need to move that window I
am shocked anyway sorry I that's
irrelevant but but okay so now that
looks pretty big to me and particularly
it looks really big compared to this
what determines the size of that system
font ooh I don't know if they brought
that back so you can change it but if my
memory serves me correctly it is a nine
point font okay it's it's it's somewhere
in control panel they might have allowed
yeah if you type into the search field
text size okay all right well fine I
could do that but but but well okay and
that's actually I wouldn't mind seeing
what they how they've done this text
make text size bigger yeah if you drag
the slider slightly you can make it
bigger but you can't make it small any
smaller than that it wait wait a minute
wait wait wait wait wait
okay so this here change the size of
apps and text on other displays okay
that's right but this is the main
control that we've got here yeah that
has influence over everything right and
okay so wait a minute so this is this
here I'm gonna do this this may be
horrifying again Oh Oh help oh my god it
just said it said please wait and then
okay so what this now did what did this
do this changed the chrome the windows
Chrome settings so to speak but not
change the in application settings
correct because what that did was is it
basically adjusts the chrome font sizes
I mean we respect our font designations
are absolute values 12 whatever know the
system ones are week week we call them
symbolic because that we're just
referencing them from whatever the
system did so basically anything that
touched the system would have updated
because you changed the fonts okay so
why are we not sizing our default
everything based on the system based on
what people set for the for this quote
sample text why are we not basing it on
the system setting for text size because
it's based on points that's what it's
documented to be based on because what's
based on points
no I think what he's I think what you
saying is why is for instance the font
size for standard form 13 as opposed to
having it be for instance the value that
comes from the system exactly or the
value that comes in system plus 2 or
something whatever it is because that
way if somebody adjusted their you know
presumably somebody is adjusting this
because you know given their monitor in
their eyesight and their whatever else
they want to get bigger that's exactly
why they put that back to by the way it
was it's an accessibility thing I
understand I understand it but my
question is why are we not keying our
sizes and by the way none of the other
apps I have up here are keying their
sizes to this either but why are we not
keying our size our font sizes to the
setting of that you know overall thing
mm-hmm
I mean this is so this is so confusing
I mean well area lighting they're
alighting the fact that this display
thing doesn't really affect very much
because then they're saying the size
were apps and text on the main screen
well yeah I mean they say that because
they know that you know apps that are
built respect you know with certain
hard-coded font sizes and they wouldn't
it wouldn't adjust to it what what did
their UI guidelines say about all the
stuff ooh I haven't looked recently I
don't know the answer it would take me a
while they dig that Guardian what
specifically what to do with font sizes
what their recommended font size is for
text and so on and how it's supposed to
be determined so I mean the issue here
okay to me this is the big smoking gun
the fact that it it already scaled up to
150% so no so I mean if we have a
symbolic size then one thing that you
risk is that
you know this is a size that's going to
change on every machine you know that
you loaded on if if the size of a label
and a graphic and you know tick labels
for example you know are based off of
size that is dependent upon your machine
and we determined how to avoid collision
based on that size you know then it may
look very different on other systems and
may look you know but what we
dynamically determining those collisions
on the client side at render time ah
know though they're being determined at
compute time it would be it would be
very computationally expensive so if I
have a graphic hold on if I have a
graphic you're telling me so let's let's
try this a lot of the kind of stuff that
Brett does to avoid there are a few
things that we do with with tick labels
to try to you know in the in the common
case of you know graphics and graphics
3d but there are a lot of cases where
you know somebody in Brett's group is
you know is doing something considerably
more sophisticated and and they can't
rely on the logic that lives in the
front end
and what you're doing I think is a good
example of that okay it's good a higher
density let's see what this does okay so
if we go like this everything's
hunky-dory right although those dots got
bigger we go like this am i seeing those
things no no I'm seeing those get closer
together because the dots are getting
closer together but I'm not seeing the
fonts rearranged right because the fonts
are at a fixed size their fixed point
size yeah now if I went down here to 75%
and so it seems I wasn't sure if this
would be the case that so it seems are
the little call-out ticks those don't
seem to be resizing either
yeah they don't
okay boy what a mess okay so let's let's
go through the facts again okay so we're
using thirteen points by default word is
using eleven point by default that
correct yeah first of all style sheet
yes okay so on a Mac would I thought
it's using eleven point but looks okay
how can that be the case now my word use
is twelve on it's a default blank
document maybe it chooses what maybe it
determines that based on the size of the
display or something I mean that would
be yet another crazy degree of freedom
here yes I have no III doubt would
listen listen on a laptop that I have
here my word started and its default
magnification was a hundred and twenty
six percent is that because I left it
like that or is probably wait a minute I
can't have left it like that because it
isn't even activated it's not even
letting me tight so like mine on my
Macintosh is and ninety-five percent and
I don't know why that is but you know it
might very well be because I fiddled
with it at some point I think we are
looking for gremlins where they don't
exist
I think the or where they you know I
think it's defaulting I think it's
changing the magnification by default
that is I think that it's it's actually
um I love the work fact that there's a
article called how to mas no no because
if if I take a blank document I change
the magnification close the document and
quit Word and restarts okay so yeah what
it's every document it says it remembers
them yeah
another thing that we could do is to
remember that because that wouldn't be
crazy if somebody says I don't like it I
mean so that's obviously how word is
dealing with this there in other words
if you set this to 75% then by default
everything goes to 75% back perhaps mmm
what if you open somebody sends you a
notebook at 10% then you close it what
do you mean no but the whole point is
Jeremy good that the decision we made
with respect to the cloud is what you
deploy when you deploy unless you insist
otherwise magnification drops off okay
so it looks to me like it looks to me
like word on Mac basically is treating
magnification as at least when you're
opening a single window at a time as a
global setting so I missed that what do
you just say what being its treaty
magnification as a global setting if I
only have one window open at a time
so like I open a file I changed
magnification I close the file without
saving it I open a different file and
whatever magnification I said last time
I get into the next file from so in
other words it's got non-local it's got
non-local communication of magnification
from the file you had before right file
but that's not what happens if you have
multiple windows open at once which is
something different and I haven't quite
understood that yet oh my gosh this is
such an unbelievable mess but I think
that the way that Microsoft is dealing
with this forward appears to be that
they are essentially so somebody says
this looks stupid so they change the
magnification and then it magically uses
that same magnification or somebody says
I don't like it because I can't read it
cuz it's too small for me they change
the magnification and then that
magnification becomes their default and
so they just think oh this is fine
yeah so I mean you know that's that's
not something that we've ever done
before we couldn't do it but it would it
would create some backward compatibility
concerns
okay let's actually we got a bunch of
comments on the live student let's just
look at some of these some amusing ones
here but but um
flip is talking about the the
implications for vision science research
of all of these crazy settings let's see
Bob is saying okay so Bob is saying in
high DPI mode you want the menus to be
bigger but but we don't control that
that's controlled by the OS I mean it's
writing those up there
now what happens if how do I get a
dialog box what's a good dialogue for me
to get a fine dialogue for example the
easiest dialog box I mean okay just fine
but that's is that who that but that's
our dialogue that's not as well that's
that's our dialogue with all the font
sizes based off of the the system font
sizes right it like so the buttons have
the right font size that correspond with
all the other buttons on the OS so that
that would have in you know should have
barring bugs followed that followed that
little slider okay you know what
this is kind of interesting and maybe we
can ask the people on livestream so
several people here so flip is saying
his word his word is a hundred and
seventy seven percent fossil is saying
his word is using eleven point at two
hundred percent so I think what we're
learning is that word in like my one on
this machine is one hundred and twenty
six percent even though and this is what
confuses me even more even though the
slider that says you know minus two plus
is right in the middle see what I'm
saying
so like where is the slider is this okay
okay so so here's here's what we can do
we can we can blame Apple for this
because they're they've conceded that
they've screwed things up
if you look at pages which is Apple's
word processing the application you'll
see that their default font size or
their default font is of Helvetica neue
11 points and their default
magnification 125 percents so women so
they're saying so what do you then see
do you see the equivalence of do you see
something that looks like ICT then you
see something that looks like our
thirteen point font that is the width is
our default 13 point font so in other
words in a different world we would
reset our default to eleven point yes by
the way would and then but then we would
set our default magnification to 125
percent on Mac yeah and that's that's
what I'm analogizing here yes right now
let's talk about printing for a second
because right now we're doing yes
another hack which everybody else has
done too which is rescaling for printing
right well and you know here you know we
here we've always been serious about you
know points being points but but we've
gone through the stylesheet and we've
said well but in the printing
environment some things are actually
smaller you know so font sizes are a
little different that's what we did with
the printing style environment yes yes
once upon a time we actually had a
global magnification of 80 percent with
some tweaks I don't think we do that
anymore I think instead we maintain the
magnification but we like specifically
so here's an alternative strategy we can
adopt okay okay the radical strategy
will be changed to the default Oh so it
since we're talking about that why don't
you just change the screen environment
to printing print out right now see what
it looks like
Oh oh my gosh
well okay looks good that's 80% right
that looks very nice yeah yeah that's
that's roughly 80% right so that's the
equivalent but but we are we are
magically changing it to 80% rather than
letting the magnification change it to
80% so another thing that we could do
then is - that will be another wiggle
room for us is to change our screen
environment say working - high DPI for
example and then auto magically change
the sizes by virtue of us of a style
environment oh okay okay I stand
corrected I'm looking I'm I was going
from memory and I would my memory was
wrong the printout environment has a
default magnification of 72% globally
applied and then there are other Perce
tile tweaks of course but okay so but
what the Mac is doing there is it saying
it's 11-point and then on a printer if I
print it it will come out 11-point but
when I see it on the screen it's 125
percent magnified because that's the
default for pages yes okay which of
course you know there's a drop-down you
can change you can change but the
advantage of that is that the thing that
is very apps okay the claim here is that
it is more absolute - printed on a sheet
of paper than it is to see it on your
screen which is reasonable and well I
mean you know historically that has
definitely been true because when we you
know did the legacy system in 1996 you
know every operating system had a way to
query what the resolution the monitor
was but no operating system ever knew I
mean you know they had no idea and they
just you know in 1996 you know Mac just
always says 72 and Windows just always
said 96 yeah and if you looked if using
a projector right the thing could be a
each character could be 3 feet tall
no how would it possibly know what the
final deployed sizes yeah yeah although
on a piece of paper because it's you
know there is a more convincing final
deployed size so you know I mean we're
getting closer these days you know it
with Mack Mack isn't really trying
because it's you only got 72 and 144 but
windows you know is making some
approximation to try to and it's they're
probably and you know places where it
goes wilfully wrong but it's making some
approximation to get a real size yeah
except when you're using a projector for
example right right a projector and just
imagine what real size means when you
have a VR display for example there
I mean it's it would be wonderful to
define that you know angular angular
diameter of a character and your visual
field or something um okay so what are
we gonna do so let's let's again review
our options that should we have a number
of interesting comments on the live
stream that we just look at these um
various people complaining about the
fact that this is a big mess um Steve's
saying don't use word as a guide well we
can use pages to our web browsers to web
browsers do anything why do web browsers
not have this issue
what do web browsers do there are more
modern stack um
I don't I'm not sure that I have a
really good answer for that but yeah I
mean you know I mean maybe Jeremy might
even know a little more than I do I mean
the question is you know first of all it
only matters if your HTML has an actual
point size specification oh yeah that's
a good point it's only ma with H ones
and things so your browser gets to
decide what well let's talk about that
in a second we look at some more of
these comments um okay so Leon our live
stream is saying he thinks the first
time you load something like wood it
takes the desktop display metrics to
come up with a magnification that is
what I am suspecting well it's plausible
it's difficult to confirm that but yes
is plausible right and the thing that
really surprises me on my machine and
maybe other people could verify or deny
this is that on my random Mac that I
have here the the the thumb for the
plus/minus size is in the middle even
though it says 126 percent as the
magnification you see what I'm saying
yeah
and that's what makes me suspicious that
it knows something more than you know
you go what I'm saying that it knows
that it deduced that somehow I mean I
can go look at another actually yeah um
actually very very confusingly I can use
the KVM switch to look at my other Mac
hold on the so one of the things which
we are working through right now is how
does rasterize work okay okay hold on
I'm just looking at some more of these
comments complaints about data set sighs
do we look at that is there a problem
with that
I can I can imagine why that wouldn't be
the case it's I mean it's probably
[Music]
applying pretty granular Styles I mean
the you know that this is it's not
necessarily unique to data set I think
you would see the problem with any
summary blob for example that it'll
respond to magnification but it or it
should at least but it won't respond
necessarily to font size okay um Oh
presented notebooks with high DPI what's
the story with that well I mean actually
much of presenter notebooks is already
pre scaled it's trying to circumvent
absolute sizes so but but so for as
another example of the data why did this
why did this not work how did I win it
look by the way these buttons aren't
fully drawn yeah yeah this is kind
HiDPI detritus that okay let me also
comment I don't know that specific this
looks really stupid these these controls
up here are miss sized welliton what
happens if I go to 75% of the controls
change size no no so where did the size
of those controls come from well to be
honest I don't know where all the font
sizes came from but they the doc cell is
just hard coded to the magnification 1
right it's not I mean you know think
about it it's not typically the case
that that toolbars would respond to a
magnification change no I understand
that but I'm just saying that toolbar
looked wrong okay so this is now oh look
at that so that is okay so the toolbar
looks totally wrong here but let's see
what happens if I say start presentation
well that was nice you know I mean this
is all scaled stuff so this is gonna
work okay fine we should changed except
except actually one thing that's not
scaled is the tick labels I know the
tick labels look scaled here but these
aren't scaled those look like they're
system controls yes yes do we think it's
I mean I think it's wrong that they're
not scaled I mean if you were doing a
presentation this would look wrong yeah
it's I mean I can understand it's it's
difficult for the implementer of
presenter tools to kind of crawl inside
of everything like this and and and
changes but okay but that that is it I
would I would consider to be a bug right
now
okay I'm gonna get out of here
boy do we really want
mr. cloud at the bottom underneath an
presentation
yeah that seems wrong to me I mean you
know who's very wrong you're presenting
you and by the way the public we are
gonna put it up yeah no I don't think
you're gonna do it in the middle of a
presentation except the one thing you
might like to do is publish the cloud
and then put up a QR code that shows you
know in place of your presentation
here's the QR code for the presentation
that will be pretty cool well so what
I've suggested independently is that you
don't necessarily need a live you know
like publish dialog or something like
that you can when you publish you can
get a QR code that you can copy and
paste into your presentation I
understand that but I think I think if
somebody had just given a presentation
and they modified things during the
presentation then it would be pretty
cool to be able to say publish this
presentation as given to the cloud and
put up a QR code well I don't know if
everyone would agree with pretty cool is
it really cool when you watch somebody
open the save dialog and type in file
names is that pretty cool in the middle
of the presentation I don't know no I
mean well I mean but if you're
publishing in the middle it seems like
sort of the same sort of thing like you
know you didn't well yeah but I mean if
the publish to cloud if all it does is
it publishes to an anonymous URL and
then just puts up the great big you know
QR code that seems like a good pretty
nice thing to do well I'm just
questioning how many people actually
well nobody's at doing that but I've
been doing that with QR codes it's
really nice ok in a case that that's a
separate thing can we can we pick that
up in a different I mean that that's a
presenter tools meets I mean that that
dialogue element is not right right now
so we need to discuss that separately we
put that a user assistance or what a I
think it's already in the user
assistance queue actually all right fine
but it can't go okay fair enough so that
thousand down there is using the system
I don't know what it's using do you have
any idea what that's using well
so let me let me show you another
example I just type in like control
equals Chicago or something like that
and now select the cell and do control
control equal plus whatever to make the
font larger I'm sorry Alt alt that back
control I'm doing equals multi-core
uh-oh it selected again
lt-col there you go notice the Chicago
gets bigger and the city doesn't so this
is the sort of thing that's you know I'm
just pointing out that this kind of
thing happens in a number of different
contexts and it's the only way to fix it
is basically to force every font size
and every control to be relative to some
other font size everything has to be
scaled and we're done it's like this to
work now is ultimately what has to
happen I write well now now if you're if
you're scaling with magnification
doesn't matter because magnification
magnifies everything but if you're but
in this case you're not scaling
magnification is scaling the font size
and there's a fixed farm size you know i
desert number of points around the word
city okay hold on I just want to UM
house is useful someone is giving us a
blog from Microsoft on how they do their
scaling
what is you WP
that's this platform right which is what
relative to what we're using so that is
their latest and greatest application
framework building environment it's it's
their way of trying to say build one app
and have it run on arm and tablets and
what used to be phones but I mean not
anymore but once upon a time it was okay
have we read this have you seen this in
oh yeah yeah yeah I've read it many
times over the years so what are we a
system scale factor app or a scaling
unaware app or a dynamically scaling up
I think we're a dynamically scaling app
but it seems like word has as an initial
condition a system scale factor app and
then becomes dynamically scaling I mean
that is basically what that is saying is
is that like for instance you start
let's say you start the front end and it
reads with the the scale information is
of the system right now when it starts
and then it uses that forever
the the dynamically scaling one is my
you know my display is at a certain you
know 150 percent I take another monitor
and I plug it in and that monitor let's
say I set for two hundred and fifty
percent so it's bigger you know pixels
are bigger the if we're a dynamically
scaling app if you take our window from
one and move it to the other it's
supposed to dynamically adjust to that
new modern and that's what ours does so
ours is per monitor dependent so you can
go from one monitor and it looks you
know has certain sizes and and then you
move it to another one and the text will
adjust accordingly depending on what the
density of the moderates
scaling unaware ones are what twelve Oh
and earlier are where it doesn't know
anything about it and so Windows does a
bit blit in order to be able to make it
so it still works kind of sensibly
depending on what display you're on
yeah and the list of example apps you're
seeing there I wouldn't trust that
because this this blog is four years old
so you know it's no longer true that
Microsoft products is hid in the system
scale factor where do they fit they was
in the dynamic scaling right and and and
and Chrome recently I think in the last
I don't know twelve to eighteen months
something like that went to dynamic
scaling okay so wait a minute so
ndynamics good so what would we do if we
were doing dynamic scaling what would
that mean for what we do well I mean it
means that you know for example when you
when you move between monitors
everything changes highs if I mean if
the monitors are different scales and I
mean okay so I just did this with them
like with an iPad as an extension for a
laptop screen right would you let okay
so duet itself direct I mean set the
scale I I don't know what you would have
the scale setup but do it can so I know
that I reset it because I didn't want it
to do whatever it was doing where it was
doing something completely crazy where
it was completely invisible and and and
and so Mac and Windows you know have a
slightly different effect what will
happen on Mac is that when you're
dragging from one display it's one
another that you won't actually see the
window on the other display until your
mouse pointer crosses over and so the
window only shows up on the screen where
your mouse pointer is when you're
dragging Windows on Windows what will
happen is you will see the windows on
both displays but if they're different
scaling then the window will look
gigantic or small on the wrong display
until your mouse pointer what what about
content of the window well is the same
yeah but the moment your I forget
whether it's when the mask
opponent-process over or whether it's
when money lost was over when the sunset
of the window cuz yeah in any case then
suddenly everything resizes underneath
you to the you know to the new modern
except it won't in our case because like
as you point out some of the graphics
things up already determine so it'll
just look stupid
no no so so what it'll do is it'll just
it so the the the point size doesn't
change between the two it's just the
number of pixels that it takes will
change between the two yeah that's that
that's the change so the difference is
the thing that he was showing was to say
he was forcibly changing the font size
but some of them are hard-coded and so
therefore they can't react to changes in
font size around it okay so it's
equivalent to magnification this change
of physical pixel size should be
equivalent to magnification it basically
is yes yes I mean it you know it has the
same it has the same fundamental
property in that it's global at least
throughout the inside of the notebook
window okay the the the one place where
they differ is that magnification
doesn't change the window size whereas
scaling does magnification yes I
understand I understand
right okay flip has done some empirical
work his machine Mac OS with 200 dpi
screen 72 point font renders at 56
points on the screen
scaling word to 125 points okay
okay Illustrator and InDesign when you
ask for 72 points at a hundred percent
its drawn as 72 points on the screen
brian is saying the fundamental problem
is that Microsoft is what they call
effective pixels yeah I mean that's
that's the okay
all right let's unravel what what is
going on here okay my my suggestion I
think there's few possibilities here
my suggestion is the least horrifying is
to set the default magnification based
on you know when you first start
notebooks to set the default
magnification based on looking around
and seeing what we can see about your
monitor put it on a different monitor
it's not going to work you'll have to
change it but then to have the a newly
created window I may regret this this
may be stupid a newly created window
they can barely use Windows you know you
won't regret anything right I'm I want
to use Windows more I like the way it
looks right now but Tim in any case the
but we'd have to do this on all
platforms I mean there has to be uniform
so then then what we would do is take
the magnification of any newly created
window from the most recent
magnification setting that makes sense
so in other words at T equals zero when
you first install we are attempting to
determine a reasonable magnification
setting well I think the only thing we
can do is introduce a new a new
magnification setting which we had once
upon a time and then we removed it but
we hadn't really but is there any chance
that we could get a continuously
variable magnification thing well in
principle the only reason
we're not doing it now I mean it that
works now you know it's you know you
could you know hook it up to a dynamic
slider and and it would work the problem
is that we have some implementation
issues where it consumes an awful lot of
resources going through the you know
when you're if you're dragging through
we're not doing a great job at garbage
collecting some system resources and
that's why we haven't you know changed
the drop down to a slider or something
like that okay
it's it's on our list of things to deal
with it's just you know one of these
legacy crud things we have to deal with
but we could have more levels here we
can have it you know today if you want
magnification of you know 93 points I
know right and we could provide some
type in thing or something to let you do
that if we really wanted to but I mean
my concern here is that the only way to
do this really is to have an independent
magnification option which would also
for example effect window size what do
you mean well oh you mean yeah because
the the yeah I mean because the the
visual trick it's really easy in word to
go around and change the magnification
because you have a fixed page size so so
as you change the mag the view display
is is pretty consistent other than right
when we would rewrite if you change
magnification we would have because we
got fixed window size we would rewrap a
bunch of stuff right that's that's the
way it works down but you know it you
know if you save a document on one plot
one platform and it sets a particular
window size and it's gonna look
different when you open another platform
settings like settings like the size of
the default helps you or the size of a
new notebook these sorts of things these
are all going to be different okay so
here's the big question
the big question is if you gosh this is
so messed up I mean if you have
something you have a notebook like I
have notebooks that I have by default
set at like 30 percent magnification
right because I just want to see a lot
of stuff on the screen and I don't
usually want to drill in I just need to
see headings mostly okay and then but
what you're saying is if if we did this
thing where it ignores the magnification
when it is deployed on another machine
how would it even know I mean if the
notebook is stored in like Dropbox or
something and it's or network file
system and it's the same notebook where
would it even remember what the setting
was on a particular machine well I mean
essentially what I'm suggesting is that
you know we already have notebook
magnifications
what I'm suggesting and and and it has
certain features one of its features is
that it gets saved into the notebook if
you change it from the default yep
another one of the features by the way
is you know kind of a weird one but
useful I think is that if you set global
magnification to say you cyclomatic
ation 200 percent or whatever it wants
oh two hundred percent in the drop-down
it's 100 percent of the ambient
magnification is what it should so what
I'm what I'm suggesting is that we could
have a global only option something that
never gets saved into notebooks but
which can get multiplied into the
effective magnification okay and that
which is equivalent to the videos and
then that could be settable from the
preferences diet which is exactly now
look at what they did here right so
notice that's not a slider wonder why
they don't make that a slider I'll tell
you why you because if you I think if I
record correct me if I'm wrong um but I
think that
you can set it to specific values but if
you do it forces you to reboot your
system because it has to like wreak oh
that's right it says that yeah it said
that it said it said you might have to
reboot yeah yeah in in Windows 7 they
actually gave you a little ruler and you
could actually like drag select how much
how how much dpi you want yeah if you
wanted a hundred twenty nine percent
magnification yeah yeah you could get it
yeah yeah that was deprecated that was
deprecated in in in Windows 8 and and
the main and the main reason I would
guess I'll venture out on a limb here
then maybe I shouldn't but I will I'm a
venture guess is that if you start doing
like the oh I'm gonna allow it to be two
hundred and twelve dpi they have they
have fixed scaling you know per bitmap
assets there's there's fixed you know
multipliers that they use and then now
all the sudden you start getting into
weird cases where you can't draw bitmaps
at all and that's hard enough to do in
this world in the first place and it
would be really hard to get it right in
that world hey this is a Ethan our live
stream suggested trying this and this is
very weird that this is so big anybody
understand why this is so big dynamic
thing is super cool but it don't know
whites oh I see magnificus 400% okay so
to this beautiful because this is
looking right this is looking wonderful
okay so this was a success whatever was
done to make this work it was a success
um I don't know where the things like
okay um okay so your proposal John is
that there is a global just like so in
other words what's happening is this is
so freakin crazy
it's just crazy so the operating system
perhaps we can get that number right
what from the operating system I don't
mm-hmm yep we already do okay and then
we can say okay based on what we know
we're going to recommend a default
setting that is where we D magnify
things to correct for the magnification
that was done by the operating system
well I I think the default would just be
for Windows and Linux would just be a
straight 75% because you know what we're
doing today
assumes sending to dpi which you know
those operating systems tend to scale to
you know ninety six or something based
off of 96 so essentially what we're
doing is a revision of a early 90s hack
with printers right the earlier that the
hack with printers is make it 80% yeah
and so what we're doing is we're redoing
that hack now for screens yeah seems
like a reasonable solution so one
advantage in tell me what you think
about this so as you said when we print
we are then we are then essentially
removing the hack because we've got the
same magnification for printing as we do
for for display at least relative to the
write-up magnification done by the
operating right and we're already doing
something similar with magnification
itself I mean regardless of what you set
for magnification if you set it at the
notebook level or the global level it
has no impact on printing right by the
way Leon our livestream has come to the
same conclusion that we have that we
want a global default well not their
thing default font size but but this is
okay look I think this is a solution
okay and are we going to you're saying
we just set it at 75 percent and be done
with it
75 percent on Windows Linux and 100
percent on Mac and then it's resettable
somehow it would be in the Preferences
dialog because this would be a global
only setting yeah and I think this would
be easier than the previous
act magnification that we have because
all it has to do is participate in
notebook level stuff and it will you
know filter into that ambient
magnification that we compute for
notebooks and then it's out of the
picture from there on out okay
I like the solution okay all right can
we continue I I know you have other
things we want to defend us yeah okay
what's the next horrifying thing okay
well so let's let's talk about rasterize
what does rasterize do right now for its
its rasterization choices how does it so
does it go ahead so what what's
basically the automatic behavior is I
think what you're asking um so the
automatic behavior is this it goes out
and looks at I know fingers are not
reprogrammed for this it so so what it
does is is that when you ask it to
rasterize something and you don't
specify any other options it goes
through and first goes through and
enumerates all the displays that are on
your machine to find out what is me
excuse me look at that thing there what
the heck is that I mean what is that
well I know what it is but why is it so
big because once again it's a control
with the magnification hardwired to a
hundred percent I see but in your global
scheme that thing would 75 percent of
eyes oh yeah that's the tricky part
isn't it yeah yeah that will require
some thought okay I mean I actually
don't think it's terrible that big bit I
think its design isn't quite right given
okay go ahead so so so so rasterize what
it does right now is it basically goes
what's the densest monitor that I have
and it will rasterize so that it looks
so basically you always have the most
pixels possible to rasterize it without
getting completely in totally crazy
so in Mak terms that would be if I had
a Retina laptop and like a really old
crummy monitor hooked up to it if I do
rasterize I would get out a retina
version of it even if I rasterized it on
the old crummy monitor that doesn't look
so good and it's and it's non retina but
did this be magnify mm if I remember
correctly that does not that does not in
this current form so basic so basically
the the mo for this is to make the
prettiest picture possible without you
know if you if you give it no other
inputs prettiest picture consistent with
what you are busily seeing on your
screen
oh no I'm you're on your machine on your
necessarily the screen I can't imagine
this is a good idea I would have thought
we should just have fixed the resolution
of rasterize and just decide what it is
well so do you really want on your nice
Retina display to rasterize is 72
because fixed seems better somehow that
doesn't we just rasterize it okay how
close in terms of just what human eyes
can see if we rasterize that the rest of
the display resolution what is it 144 or
something
yes would that not be a good solution
well it's so it's not a very good
solution if you're on a 300 percent
scaled system is it on well 144 dpi as
opposed to you know as 140 so what
you're saying
percent scaled system is twice the
resolution reported resolution of a
retina by the way I just like to point
out how ridiculous it is that we're
getting those extra things and they also
complete their I scored that fact
oh yeah no those shouldn't be there all
right so now what is I don't even know
what those authors suggest okay
okay so now now here's here's something
everything we've been talking about you
know so raster size is pixels okay it
makes a difference if you're it if you
give the same you know if you're gonna
talk about pixels that means that on
your retina display it's going to have
an apparent size you know of half what
it is on the other yes hey I've got
another trivial point is for a design
folk I really think those books are
incomprehensible I think it's the wrong
iconography I think it has to be
something that indicates a link off to
that I think we already have parts don't
we already have something feeding into
the user assistance meaning about that I
think we do yeah we I mean it just needs
to be something that is more of a go off
to documentation type thing okay so what
what are we trying to see here that was
what the heck did that - oh that's the
that's the overall raster size across
the whole that is a hundred pixels but
but you know obviously a I mean you know
if you count them it's a hundred pixels
across and that is the documented
behavior what's wrong with that
I mean that's what yeah yeah yeah but so
I mean what we're doing is we're and I
don't have a complete list maybe maybe
Savion folks can help kind of enumerate
some of the issues but I mean basically
we need to tighten the screws down on
you know what is image size what is
rasterized what is image resolution and
how do these three things interact with
one another and so for example for
example image size is documented to be
in points it's documented everywhere to
be in points but it's documented in also
in rasterized to be in points I think
that we need points for a fake
but-but-but-but some people have used
the image size as a proxy for pixels by
the way that I was the wrong side
let this be magnified anyway you know
that yeah but image size has been used
by some folks as a proxy for pixels and
so they rasterized something with a
specific image size and they they expect
to call image dimensions on it and get
what they put in for image size well
that's just gonna be wrong that's going
to be wrong yes I bet I've done that
actually because I didn't really
understand well and other people inside
the company have done that too okay let
me understand this again okay so so
we've got image size which was
supposedly in points yes okay okay but
um so what would happen okay okay I
understand so image sizes and points but
what obviously rasterize is committing
itself to a certain number of pixels
because that's what it does right so you
know our claim our claim is that image
size shouldn't have anything to do with
the number of pixels that rasterize
creates what image size has to do with
is you know final displayed sighs I
don't displayed size yes so what I
should be able to do is to say raster
size 100 so here's an interesting test
if I say raster size 100 and image size
100 what do I get you get I don't know
what you get here because I really wrote
this back and then forward so this up
today of go ahead go ahead
the the final result and I have a demo
here ready to do it notebook and ready
to demo for you is that will be
rasterized at the hundred pixels and
then displayed at a hundred points so do
you want you want to share sure
go ahead and if you happen to be on a
macintosh where a point equals a pixel
then you get that not necessarily on
other platforms okay so if I call this
this is rasterize of a disk the image
size is 200 and the image resolution
okay like this is image resolution I can
do the same with your processor size but
can say rust size is gonna be 100 then
this this is displayed as 200 but the
number of pixel is 100 by 100 here okay
exactly would you expect then if I check
here this is 200 by 200 great sense
oh the whole percent is yo-yo is your
physical rescaling with the resize
handles you know I'm just clicking here
too - no no I understand well I'm just
looking at that where it says 100 100
percent 100 point 7 percent that's a
little weird
it's it's like your resize handles were
slightly nudged yeah I think I just
moved ok fine but so and this is
actually the backward compatible thing
that we are doing and the writing the
value thing is a fixed basically because
previous to today image resolution an
image resize couldn't really work
together because image resolution was
just ignored when you specified image
size which is what kind of weak answer
image resolution is so in that case okay
so if you were to give raster size if
you were to give all three image size
image resolution that implies a raster
size but if your exercise is well it's a
image size image size has nothing to do
with the number of pixels I guess we but
raster size and image resolution yes
only one of them can be relevant because
they both specify the same thing but but
when you said it has nothing to do with
the number of pixels if you include
image resolution image size does have
something to do with the number yes yes
yes a little more technical than that
because I mean this is here yeah this is
receive roster size overrides image
resolution this has been documented here
forever it's still the case so we are
just doing what we were doing we will be
saying with weekly good so this is this
is gonna be 100 okay now if you meet
what's the image resolution 144 is
because your actual screen is resolution
144 oh I just put it here I mean I can
put anything here now I can put any
number this would be ignored raster size
is that but if you put 144 there show me
with 144 resilient resolution 144 and
image size 100 100 yeah so now how many
pixels is that so click on that this is
200 because I'm under 144 like this is
image size is in points yeah so 100 in
points means 100 pixels sorry yeah image
was what now I'm confused what does the
72 have to do with anything you're
saying this is now 1 1 point 1 1 point
is 1 over 72 inches okay fixed it's 100%
magnification what units is image
resolution dpi
is big fill per inch okay hey here's a
little random point we should obviously
support units in these and it might help
make things clearer yes this is a nice
idea so if I you know and we've been
talking about doing some stuff in the
front end as well but it just you know
it can't make it for twelve one yeah I
understand but at least at the level of
the kernel and rasterize we could
support just okay so right now if you
see this thing I can even drag it up
this I I'm putting this ruler here
exactly for this reason so this here
thing here image high 72
is exactly one inch and it has X twice
as many pixel as points because I'm on
this type of display if I say a
resolution 72 nothing changing the size
but now it has 72 pixels per inch okay
okay standard resolution so we are we
are red we are doing good with the
scaling here now by the way
even our live streams ask about export
that depends on the image format that
you use but we beyond that I'm not
really image formats but you can you but
we don't have to worry about that right
because that's a separate thing the
image size on a gift for example what
does it do isn't that well is so so gif
if I recall correctly is pure pixels but
when we say image size we're not we're
not defining it with a raster we're not
admitting that it's a raster we're just
saying image size blah and we're just
taking that to be pixels and the gift
that's true statement I think it's kind
of a hack image size has always been
taken to the eraser sites
I really doubt we want to change that
that's it's a bad back backwards
incompatible yeah we don't want to
change it it's been used a million times
and right is what it is unfortunate but
whatever
but we do have to document that with
some clarity that image sizes pixels for
export so let's walk through this again
do we want to start using raster size
advertised said more and see maybe in
1020 air is difficult in my size yes for
export we could use right we could start
supporting raster size and export right
everybody is thinking of the long game
[Laughter]
John I mean you know you're talking
about I'm not being critical I'm saying
array yeah um okay
all right let's I'm sorry good let's go
back here so what is the question here
is there something that's changed what
what would happen what happen is let's
go yeah so there are two
incompatibilities with the previous
version image resolution used to be
ignored
what image died was specified now we
don't do that anymore I see I see
because image resolution has to be
there's no automatic setting is that for
image resolution or is that there is
which is your you're actually we are
also introducing this dollar image
resolution this is design pending patent
pending and this I think is useful
because you can use it you can use to
set your global value for resolution
everywhere
if you want it otherwise the automatic
what has it set to is it set by default
to automatic yeah
so dollar with this we were actually
talking about this shortly before this
meeting began and I think what we've
decided on is that it's basically the
highest resolution of any monitor you
you have connected by default by the
formatter setting yes okay but so
normally okay so it will change in a
during a session if you reconnect
another monitor yes it could okay and
less extreme than switching monitor
okay okay so women so what's the
incompatibility here that it used to be
that image resolution could be ignored
because image size was taken to be the
raster size yeah which is no longer the
case
I mean it was it was the case by chance
the point is on a seventy at a 72 dpi
resolution image size is raster size but
only at that resolution so these other
people were doing the wrong thing they
were just you know exploiting a loophole
in the system it was you could use image
that I understand so for most people
there will be no visible change
associated with it but they weren't
sitting in his resolution anyway I think
image resolution I was always confused
by what it meant so this seems fine to
me
yeah there's only a little it'll extra
thing here first image resolution has to
be
propagated in the image and as you see
here I have a fixed size image with 200
by 200 pixels and if I set different
resolution it displays at different
sizes correctly because I'm saying that
this is more and more dense so now if
the image image object is an expression
is aware of resolution then we of course
we had to teach it about resolution
because otherwise 144 dpi images or a
high-res images will display the ribbon
okay but so by default image resolution
is automatic yes but what does that mean
for like our auto sizing of images like
when you put an image in a list and
things and it auto sizes down is that
direction
let's still this still is doing that
because you see if I remove this image
size all which I just put it here
exactly to our offset that then
everything is out how to resize inside
of a list I see
okay that's fine then I reboot this back
and and just to see the actual size yeah
yep and then there's another super
technical detail which is numberless
very relevant is that what happens when
I give you an object with some non
numeric coordinates do you are you
thinking about the coordinates as in the
in points or in the pixel space
and to show what happens let me go here
I mean like an image mask right isn't
pixels isn't it
it depends those we have different
functions so like we we have like stripe
out from a rasterized page an example
that immediately fade when you switch to
high resolution was this you had these
two nice regions you annotate with
regions graphics this is all vector
stuff you asked for the bounding boxes
of the regions and then you display them
so all this procedure should be
absolutely independent of your screen
resolution but panzram regions is
returning these regions returning pixel
positions region is returning dimension
like coordinates in points but that's
wrong presumably because all our image
processing functions work in pixel
positions but but that's the point
graphics doesn't work like that and if
you do something like this where you
show a rasterized image and some other
graphics oh my gosh because the point is
that graphics is working in points
exactly yeah and so absolute size of a
dot in a graphic is based on points
correct yeah absolute point size you
mean absolute point yes sorry
so one question would be is there a way
in graphics of asking for a distance in
pixels no there are no pixels in
graphics well I know but that you could
in principle since you know the
resolution of the screen you can say I
want to move by this number of pixels
right as the N was helpfully pointing
down before you don't really know where
your point will snap before you
rasterize it's it's agreed that you have
to align somehow the alignment is not
always perfect okay but I mean for
example in those cellular automaton
images that's why we introduced pixel
constrained is because we wanted to
align our essentially graphics stuff to
the pixel grid but as John was saying
that is a no-go now this alignment is
now very no I understand that but as a
matter of of I want to make this thing I
mean graphic design folk whoo yeah the
don't you think about you know I'm
trying to make an icon I want it to be
10 pixels tall maybe you don't
do that in the modern world they then
they make a dozen icons that I'm asking
don't you want the ability within a
graphic to say I want this blob at this
point for example point as in dot I want
this dot to be such-and-such a number of
pixels across wouldn't that be a useful
thing to have right now it's all in
points and so when you scale the display
you but you need I mean how big as a
pixel you'd need to know how big a pixel
I know but I know screens but given that
we've now defined dollar image
resolution that defines how big a pixel
is because the units of image resolution
if I'm understanding correctly is pixels
per inch is that not correct yep okay so
then we know how big a pixel is relative
to points which are you let you know how
well you know how big a pixel is how big
you have to cut on the maximum size on
the maximum resolution model right but
but you have declared a pixel size
basically by setting dollar image
resolution and given that you've
declared a pixel size one can imagine
that will be useful in graphics to say
look I just want this thing to be five
pixels across to be cleared our image
resolution doesn't have any impact on
rendering it has impact on rasterization
I understand that but I'm saying we
could introduce units in graphics that
would use all they would do is to say
you know dollar image resolution divided
by 72 that's it would be that would be a
a point size obtained from dollar image
resolution by dividing by 72 right 72
divided by okay right okay fair enough I
mean that idea I Jeremy do you care
about that idea or do you think that
idea is irrelevant
I never ran into it in our language but
we deal with that an illustrator all the
time trying to make things like this
where you want to align the pixel grid
and you export out to that size in
bitmaps so if you're designing vector
and you want to export to bitmap that's
important okay so oh yeah here's one
crazy that you're saying pin that idea
for a second okay your head talked about
what you were going to talk about this
is crazy idea
so show is is from the graphics world
are always being like that and but we do
have functions to plot stuff on an image
so my far-fetched proposal here is that
we keep show in points so you see I have
an image here I'm with this slider
I'm rasterizing at different resolutions
you see the image dimension is changing
the plot range of this show is not
really changing example this sometimes
we're the nothing on one bit so this
rectangle is fixed and is not moving
around even if the image gets bigger or
smaller this rectangle will always be
drawn in the same place which is a
useful feature in in many circumstances
if you're working with only with image
measurements so you don't want that you
are measuring something on the image so
you hold on hold you're showing me what
what show does when I use show to
combine a graphic with an image is that
correct yeah the code is this is the
this one is show in this case you have
the rust and you have a graphics so
you're combining your stand so you're
changing the rest but the because what
we just understand this the position of
that red rectangle is determined by the
image size wise is understand that but
its position relative to the image is
determined by the fact that the plot
range of these graphics I understand but
we're it but the pixel the this is going
across the full extent of the image
because that's how show works
is that right
what determines how how does the plot
range map into the enter into the
position on the image oh because this
this image here I have dated the
converters so this image here knows that
it has a specific resolution and and
knows what plot range communicate to the
visualization functions absolutely can
diffuse path okay all right but so fine
so that's so this image regardless of
how many Peaks that it has will always
communicate the same plot thank you
because the image solution is is scaling
together with with dimension what I
don't know how does an image communicate
plot range because I mean you can't you
can compute it I can actually is easy if
I take it out so this is an image this
contains an array if I if I send it to
the boxes world this is a graphics box
of the raster box and this is a range
which is computed using a number of
pixels which is here and the image
resolution which right now is anywhere
because it's a 72 default but if I
change the resolution the plot range
will change the number of piece will not
change so you see no same number of
pixel different plot range and okay okay
so hold on are you showing me something
that okay is there a problem here or is
there no no no no okay yep the problem
is what happens now if this rectangle
100-150 is not a rectangle in the point
word but is the product of a measurement
on the image from an image processing
function okay in that case this means
pixel 160 150 well who says that I mean
I don't understand how the pixel you
just told me everybody's been telling me
I can't have pixel measurements in a
vector graphics but no
I'm talking about image processing
functions like I have had a real image
and image processing functions and I do
image cases I guess some bounding boxes
those bounding box is already ready to
the pixels in me but do you give those
as rectangles yes yes oh that was a hack
because those things are in a coordinate
system that isn't a graphics coordinate
system it's a bit unfortunate we updated
the every even forcing function to
return graphic primitives to versions
ago but also that was the easiest or
best way to differentiate between lies
lines and rectangles and so forth all
right so let's see highlight image so
highlight image what is doing is it
assumes that this is pixels so you see
the the plot range and the position of
the rectangle
they are gonna change because but you
see that the rectangle now is neck
alright I left with apply understand so
that's a huge mess
ok so do you have a solution I mean I
think this is a solution they could
behave the same way but I think that
highlight image is basically designed to
display stuff measured on the image
while show is designed to combine
different graphics primitives and it
converts an image to some graphic stuff
to a raster graphics you're suggesting
that highlight image if you give it
graphics primitives it will assume pixel
coordinates in the graph yep if we do I
think you should do you just told me
that we could never use pixel
coordinates in a graphics you're now
proposing that highlight image does use
pixel coordinates
yeah because highlight image is just
using as thing graphics layer on top of
an image but is meant to be a function
to display stuff on top of an image is
way more precise than than a generic
graphics it's his job right it's that we
have on our live stream here there's
some interesting things here exporting
images is important for scientific
journals yep we know that I mean
although often that's in resolution
dependent formats I would suspect
high-res displays while we're talking
about high DPI support under windows
okay flip is saying for example openexr
which we support right as an export
format is that not a desert Restatement
open an arc and check
we have import we don't have export
was that by the way Giulio is that the
end of yours should I go back to my
screen oh yeah please
um yeah I'm not seeing it in our export
lists is it in the import list though
yes okay um okay
so a flip is saying specifies an
attribute X density which is horizontal
output density in pixels per inch what
the heck is that telling one I mean
especially for a cinema format where it
depends how far away the projector is
from the screen how big it's gonna be
what an earth does it mean when it says
pixels per inch okay I'm confused by
that um well I'm confused by that
particular point as well but in general
though you know the notion being that
any raster format that has enough
metadata to you know be able to
understand a notion of resolution it
seems reasonable that we would want to
be able to support that I see a
resolution as well as I get it I get the
point I get the point so in other words
we should give in the metadata we can
say in the exporter we can have an image
resolution option people can set
independent of the image size though
they could set so in other words okay I
understand now yeah and there are many
raster formats which aren't rich enough
to support this but some are okay so
hold on maybe maybe we can get ourselves
out of the gift raster size bind in the
following way we've got a triple we've
got raster size aventure size and image
resolution right we agree that either
image size and image resolution together
determine number of pixels or raster
size determines number of pixels so in
the case of gift where people are just
setting image size then assuming let's
see you're saying image size what are we
then assuming about image resolution
we're assuming that image resolution is
set to automatic in such a way that
image size coincides with pixels right
if we say that then we're then we're
good then we then we've then gift stays
with image size stays a pixel
specification so in other words the
default image resolution for exporting
to a gif is such that the the image
resolution the automatic setting of
image resolution for export is precisely
that image resolution which makes image
size equal to raster size I think that
will work
do we want to explicitly set that in the
images that have the location for that I
don't know well we should find out what
formats actually have an image
resolution metadata format you know a
specification which may not be very many
of them but let's find out what they are
and if that's the case if somebody has
set image size but has not set raster
size and it's not said image resolution
we should decide what to do but we might
want to set it that way yes sure okay so
we got a solution to that so we don't
have to you know we don't have to kill
image size for gif export
for EXR export maybe we do but since we
know even have EXR export we haven't
crossed that bridge yet and we can do it
correctly whatever correctly means um
Ethan our live stream is supporting the
idea of pixel perfect position of
graphics together okay what would happen
if you use show with arguments and image
in a vector field I think that will work
just fine right giulio vector plots um
yes ah why are some formats not
supported for both import and export um
what is the answer that why is our
openexr not supported for export it
seems like it'd be easier to do export
and import some some formats are very
different like SVG import is quite
complicated where as SVG export because
they're things in SVG that are usually
import is harder because there are
things that SVG you know has a 300-page
specification or something and we don't
necessarily have well yeah or or you
know EPS which your PostScript is very
incomplete yes right yeah right so what
do we do right so we so to import every
possible EPS is hard and I don't know
why you open the XR doesn't have export
Saudis perhaps investigate that enough
okay so anyway this question about
vector field they don't fully understand
um I like by the way I'm perfectly happy
working on my Windows machine at 75
percent magnification here so I'm that's
good um except for the fact that that
eye is too big okay so that's that is a
very boring vector but whatever
okay so let's take our vector plot and
the question is whether this vector plot
has does something funky when it's on
top oh why is it a different color than
it is in the documentation probably
nobody here knows the answer that
reevaluating documentation I'm sure
it'll change
I'll bet just nobody's revaluated that
in a long time
oh I remember this issue this is I think
this may be a 1200 this was I think a 12
out change so path I think you're the
designated person to go go report that
there was specific to vector plot and
presumably other vector functions we
suspect okay
um our vector field obtained from an
image so how do we get so that's
something with with image corresponding
points or something if you have a vector
field obtained from an image it will
already be scaled correctly because it
will use nicely so it should be fine
it should be fine exactly let's but
let's say you have this one and you want
to display this on top of an image then
the the workaround of this is an option
option to highlight image which is that
arranged so you can put your image
highlight image image come at this yeah
and then if you say that arranges 0 1 0
1 then will align perfectly
fine but anyway there isn't a problem
because it's the it's the vector field
derived from the image input image
highlight the image is perfectly okay so
Ethan is complaining that using inset
for images and graphics and graphics 3d
can be painful for complicated figures I
mean the coordinates for inset are
relative to the zero one coordinate
system in both directions isn't that
correct
I think it's negative one to one if I
recall correctly all right anyway is
there any more
I am super late I've just run over to
other meetings but but is that any more
that we needed to cover here I mean were
you going to show a bunch of assets by
DP well I mean I mean we could we could
look at assets I don't know if there's
anything that Jeremy wants to call out
in particular but it's I mean you know
probably there's probably not a huge
amount that needs I mean most of us just
high-res improvements of what we already
have such an allele of students asking
what if you vectorized the the rasterize
directory I think that will work fine so
long as you define the the image size
somebody maybe configure that out and
send it there I think if you if you get
the image size and raster size correct
it should work okay go ahead with it
with the least um um so I don't know if
Jeremy was or anything or Billy was
there anything you want to call out in
terms of in terms of assets no really I
mean the cursors are all up to date but
it's a little hard to systematically go
through its I think yeah and actually
the cursors I have the most problems
with or kind of you know detailed bits
that are a bit difficult to get to so
yeah I mean I'm just looking at random
assets here these look a bit big I mean
these don't seem but I see that's
because there are a hundred percent yeah
at 75 percent they would look so I mean
one of the things that we're doing which
is very painful but one of the things
that we're doing is in a number of
places we're trying to dump if map
assets and replace with vector assets
you know it's done hey listen there's a
bug here because look at these tabs
these have 75% off ID themselves
relative
- imitating these menu items here I
think so in other words that was a tab
view tab use by default are using the
system fonts yeah but if you then if you
take that system font there which may or
may not be that system font so gosh what
is going on then so this is is this if I
go to 100% here the font size in that
tab view it just changed yeah mm-hmm
yeah because the magnification affects
everything right okay except that it
also so so this originally took its size
from the system fonts and then got de
magnified or D magnified yeah okay yeah
we've we've made our interfaces scaled
based on old right system font
assumptions so things are gonna be out
of sync we haven't really looked at that
yet okay or mixing kind of system bonds
with any other are there any other
pieces I should look at here I mean I'm
sure if I look at where is the if we're
really gonna do that 75 percent want to
talk about how that maps and other
things like the Docs toolbars we're
going to not affect that and I'm screen
what other places yes I think we're
gonna have to do that no question where
is the where is the preferences Oh
edit edit preferences that's a standard
thing for Windows why is this taking
forever oh my gosh look at that guy
yes that was a that was a nine point
font that got 25% taken away I mean I
know I'm not horrified by it but I got a
lot of weird stuff on here what is it
anyway
um oh look my vibe is connected to this
that's exciting
oh that's interesting that that
registered as a controller that's weird
what are these what are those
controllers are those part of the vive
stiii I have no idea I couldn't tell you
I've never seen that before
yeah valve is uh I mean it's obviously
that I'm guessing but that's part of the
vive stack now they see those are the
individual hand controllers oh oh I see
okay so if I move them around this
should move what's kind of cool all
right look we polish it can I mean we
we've we got to think through the
conclusions that we came to from this
meeting so let's take it from there um
all right horrifying stuff but I think
yeah this should this should be okay I
hope any further comments and then we
can wrap here
nope okay well thanks thank you all and
thanks to people on the livestream a lot
of very useful can't smash ated okay CEO